foreign
[Music]
as you know guys we go straight into the
IG question and the IG question of this
week was what's the one thing you never
told your ex and as per usual guys the
responses were
juicy mango juice mango juice peach
juice all at emtings
do your thing
do your thing 21. I'll get over that I
can't get over that do your thing to
anyone do your thing yeah so what's the
one thing you never told your ex he
can't rap
no yeah
[Music]
um
yeah can't rap he can't rap I should
just stay strong throughout the whole
relationship that's that's strong
because I that's sensible because yeah I
couldn't hear that
but then she's she has to suffer and
listen to him right yeah rags
so the whole time she's just thinking
brother you just can't do you just
you're not about this game all about
this life your penmanship is God it's
terrible I can write better bars
yeah that would Flatline me yeah
Flatline
my best friend is not actually gay
bro my best friend is not actually gay
he's just a brat that I let hang around
have sleepovers
brunch brunch
then when I do not avocado and salmon
this is where two questions then I'm
already like changing my perspective on
what's reality
that's what I mean
yeah he's not even gay we just said that
yep he's not actually gay at all I just
had to lie I had to lie to keep him
around because you're too sucks about
the whole thing and you have every right
to be of Rags because he's stacked
he's stacked no no no pocket wise I'm
body wise
gay was the only way it's the only way
it's LS
someone in his friendship group asked if
I was blind when I first said yes
I'm gonna read that again someone in his
friendship group asked if I was blind
when I said yes
to just being with him yes brother
are you black his boy frigma that's just
like me securing her baddest and REM
coming up to her saying are you blind
guys
Flex his Butters swags are you blind
like that could never come back to me of
course information couldn't make it back
I'll set up a ring for you man in here
we'll be doing up YouTube boxing for
real for real you have to wow are you
blind no no no no no no no no no no stop
the snake wow Slytherin and she just
didn't even bother to tell him that his
boy's moving like that didn't bother
tell me facts [ __ ] tell me
I actually cheated on him first when I
threw him out for cheating on me of
course I bet this happened a million
times fax that one's the most blatant
one folks
I was the reason he went to prison you
can't be a criminal and cheat on me
that's not true
that's what the streets is the reason he
went to prison that's what the streets
are saying
nah
nah she just
ratted him out ride them out wrong you
can't be a criminal and cheat on me she
was Fed Up You're Gonna cheat say less
she was Fed Up go Ben then [ __ ] so
cheating pen cheat in bed try try yeah
we'll have you up wow
I'd always prefer his brother's bed
hmm I always prefer his brother's bed
[Laughter]
not bro pardon family not even what
family just say it how it is don't tell
me his bed tell me you like his [ __ ] I'd
always prefer his they like to be like
they like to dabble tell me how it
really is brother's bed's more
comfortable this one is probably top
three worst ones I've ever written down
swear I used another man's money to take
care of you because you were the one I
loved
I used another man's money to take care
of you because you're the one I love
I had to do this I had to do this you're
financially broke yeah so all demanded
our hollering me
you know what I'm saying I'm sucking all
their peers I'm taking all their peace
coming your way it's coming your way
because I love you and it's the only out
we've got don't ask me where I'm getting
the money from because it's none of your
business listen to me if I heard that
information I would politely exit The
Room walk into my car legit close the
door and just sit
screaming at the steering wheel holding
turn into screaming bro what screaming
to allow what is a God I mean what is a
man
do you know what I mean screaming to him
tell me what is a man because it's not
me yeah facts but it's not me facts bro
she's providing via next there's so much
heartbreak in every word she says
Brava you're broke you can't support us
I have to support us and the way I've
been supporting us is with Real Men Real
Men Real Men Who just Dash money at me
and after after hurdle it all up I have
to get it all together just to keep us
to keep you and us afloat
don't even burden you with that
information it will oh it would you just
sit there playing Modern work like a
good little [ __ ]
because he will jump you know people
jump she knows he would jump there's no
other option scramble up the closest
building
I would do if I had that information
you'd literally see me like leap out of
the chest and start running and she'd
have to chase me you know when you start
but you know when you slide around
corners and then like
because she knows exactly where I'm
headed
you're headed for that yeah I'm headed
to take it oh my God
I broke up with him via text because I
got my [ __ ] ate at a party
she couldn't bear the thought of facing
him I broke up with him via text because
she's still at the party probably
she didn't really disclose that
information
she's like as soon as she night reality
sunken yeah she was like I can't go home
I can't go home my conscience is done
because I know I'm doing that again
because that stimulation was everything
there's no guilt here yeah
there's not a shred of guilt oh mad mad
that I oh that I still flick my being
over him whilst my man is on working
night shifts
[ __ ] hell man bro this is still flick
my being over him whilst my man Works
night shifts
what was the title of this thing called
again what's the one thing you never
told your ex these are all been women
uh so far yeah because I was gonna say
was this even
[Applause]
yeah yeah
foreign
I broke up with them because all these
toes were bigger than his big toe I just
said I lost feelings
all of his toes are bigger than a big
time pinky toes all of his toes that's
an anomaly he was a little he was
literally living in the upside down
because that doesn't make sense the
relationship never would have started
bro because I would you must have pre-ed
the toes prior yeah you spout all over
your mind just now
all of your mic just now that's that TV
interface it's making my teeth slippery
it's making my teeth slippery Jay
there's too many peas in that oh that's
jokes
it's making my teeth slippery they're
slippery
[Laughter]
slippery that's nuts
[ __ ] I'm sweating already yeah same same
uh
that I wasn't on my period I was waiting
for the SDI results to come back after
that raw dog cheated
scumbags
they're all scumbags oh and men just
can't hide lies that oh to be fair we
can't yeah it would show because our
body language and facial reactions which
is if we're not on it we're just not on
it yeah and you'll read it on us do you
think I can be with a girl who can't rap
and make it all the way to the end of
the relationship and never tell her no
no I'm telling you somehow oh I might
not say You Can't Rap but I'll probably
put on like someone that's a much better
rapping you like listen to her yeah yeah
yeah because I feel like you can gain
something from them you should know from
my body language like yeah she's like oh
I've got like this new song like can you
listen and then like she'd hit me like
yeah just just before right
yeah that's what I was saying oh yeah
wow so I would say it oh wow [ __ ] me my
stuff
that he actually did look like a piece
of melted bubble gum naked
melted bubble gum
him naked his name just like blubber
melted bubblegum bubblegum doesn't even
melt brother
and he said he actually did yeah he
actually did which basically means he
confronted you and said tell the truth
your facts do I just do I look [ __ ] yeah
do I just look [ __ ] I was like no am I a
walking skid marks like what is this
fried egg
with a burst yoke
a fried egg with a burst yolk oh yeah uh
he woke me up one night because he was
vigorously wanking next to me
oh
I
was like vigorously wanking next to me
front
front Shakey's just breathing
[Music]
he's just woken up eyes are beaming
because she's not moving his eyes are
beaming bro bro the spec must have been
pricking on her neck
now when is this gonna it's what it is
why she opened eyes she mimes to herself
what's going
firm what's going on oh [ __ ] oh bro
that's terrifying you left [ __ ] stains
on my bed when you were butt naked
[ __ ] stains
whilst we were together I used to joke
with my ex about his height
for I swear to God
whilst we were together
the most disrespectful thing I've ever
[ __ ] heard for you had are you joking
mother's world this is what the streets
are saying she got with him and then
they said he used to make jokes with her
ex about his height family what just
leave me leave me alone you know what I
mean leave me alone why are you with me
if I'm just such a clown why with me
I gave his friend head before we made
out
tough Pickins before her and her man
lips she sucked off his boy brother
yeah that will get you a face caved in
yeah
where I'm from
we're on from that will get your face
caved in
wow
[Laughter]
wow
I'm yet to tell him he's an ex he's in
my room right now
he cried didn't it he definitely cried
throwback telephone episode he
definitely cried he just cried
fam
what's the one thing you never told your
ex I'm HIV positive
and he's your ex now you just went
through the whole thing HIV positive
I'm sure you can go to prison for that
Once Upon a Time you definitely could I
don't know if that's the case now
because it's basically like chicken box
now it's minor but yeah that I don't
want the other one can you imagine
imagine you've been with her for a year
and at the end of it she said I've got
something to tell you bro I've got HIV
my my limbs wouldn't know what
it's one of those ones where
there'll have to be a funeral for her
because I'm throwing her off a cliff or
something and I will just wait for
someone to arrest me Fam because I can't
I won't be able to explain to the judge
why I didn't do what I wanted to do to
her so I just had to dash it I'd start
planning how I'm gonna compromise your
immune system
foreign
you're just gonna start finding black
mold in your in your yard oh my God
[ __ ] hell
one time I saw a cockroach sorry [ __ ] it
out
one time I saw a cockroach on her
counter I said nothing because I didn't
want to have to kill it
right that would be me
reminded of me it would have been me
right
what's wrong nothing nothing and once I
say scroll down the back of it yeah no
nothing
but you'll be on edge saying that
tonight I'm going I'm going what's your
excuse I'm just grabbing
it's not like I said it's your misses
brother what are you gonna say I'm just
going I'm just going bro and then like
you'll think I'll just probably I'll
just curate an argument about nowhere
and leave and then when I get home I'm
like big man take BMT there's a roach in
that yard
find it find it kill it then Shout
find the source because there's more
than one yeah there's definitely more
than one eggs in there I don't know it
you need pesticide get someone in to
sort it out and then let's make up
uh I peed on his hand whilst he fingered
me
let's move on from that one I don't like
that one his best friend subscribe to my
only fans oh I bet this happened a fair
few facts but that's that's sticky icky
icky it doesn't happen a few times Vicky
best friend
mad mad when she was crying in a toilet
again I
well when she was crying in the toilet
again I whispered to myself I can't wait
to end this oh oh I can't wait yeah yeah
that's this dread being a guy sometimes
because you can't do it when she's
crying
like this is literally my last year yeah
I've had enough of you and I've had
enough of this I can't wait
he's just ripping his [ __ ] hair
around yeah oh bro I've been there we
all have I've been we all have she's up
in the room crying her eyes out and I'm
just like wow I'm like what am I doing
it yeah just roll your eyes what am I
doing here dumb bro I can't wait to end
this I'll [ __ ] wait to end this yeah
man
this is stupid have you ever like
have you ever like had an argument with
your girl at the time or whatever and
then
you've obviously paused the TV to argue
and then you argue argue argue either
she storms off or she doesn't or
whatever and you're thinking when can I
unpause this thing I don't think I've
naturally never done a pause thing but I
can imagine how awkward that scenario
would be oh bro I can imagine that
awkward though I've been there bad times
when I'm thinking when's it appropriate
that I'm just like
and then just keep playing
because I'm I don't care yeah I'm done
yeah and the show is interesting and I
can't miss a piece of it yeah I'm gonna
have to rewind it yeah yeah yeah all the
best I've missed from your [ __ ]
what's wrong with the [ __ ] you were
chatting all right last but not least
um what's the one thing you never told
your ex I kept an Evidence file of all
the illegal things he did he's being
charged as we speak
wow fam this this is multiple bro
so yes let me get this straight so women
think they can just get with Road man
and then use his occupation against him
when things don't go your way yeah when
things go south when things get sticky
icky you want to use his occupation
against him yeah I've been buying new
stuff oh bro I've been buying you I love
the fact that I've always got cash on me
facts you love that about that you love
that strike fear in the streets I love
that you love a bad man always says she
wants a bad man and a soldier you loved
it you love that about me but because
you're pissed off because I'm just
slanging dick you actually think you can
put me away
you've kept a folder you better pray I
don't come out oh you better prayer
because your feelings are hurt
yeah bro do you actually understand how
mad that is outlandish outlandish you
better prayer don't come out bro
that's I can't I physically can't bear
it bro it's mad you're going jail fam
why because you're a cheat you were
cheating you hurt my [ __ ] feeling
yeah you're a heartbreaker to cheat so
I'm sending you to pen I'm a road man
bro I'm literally meant for Rose this is
my job what do you mean I'm going pen
just break up with me I literally just
believe me leave me alone I've got more
things you leave me alone leave bro find
someone better but don't send me to
prison over this I've got people to feed
bro I've got responsibilities I've been
paying my mom's rent from day bro and
then when the woman's done she doesn't
care she doesn't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
what you say you should be on the way to
the police station with a folder on the
phone to you and you're like I've
clutched in a hand I've got kids I've
got this I've got that you should have
[ __ ] thought about it before you
slunged it before you started banging
his hoes oh you idiot I'll tell yeah
I'll tell your mom myself why I'm doing
it geez they don't care anymore oh a
woman
red that's all they see it's mad
is the most dangerous the only mission
is to ruin your life yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's it you have to feel then
they're thinking he needs to feel how
I'm feeling I'm not gonna feel I'm gonna
be behind bars yeah I'm not feeling how
you're feeling I'm not crying I'm scared
for my life listen
you better prayer don't come out okay
facts cool right that's it yeah that was
it pain guys all right guys welcome back
to episode 235 of shits and gigs with
your boys J Money And Fire Lord for
example thank you so much for coming
back
um
yeah man things are going well things
are going well obviously guys if you are
enjoying the episodes which most likely
you are
um and you want a little bit more to add
to your palette you're getting a little
I don't know a little fruit burst from
that I'm packing open that fruit
yeah yeah yes your saliva glands are
open now yeah now they're open yeah now
they're receptive and you go in for
number two and there's nothing there you
have to wait till next week yeah yeah
yeah so every Monday you're just like
receptive nothing left receptive nothing
left I need a little something else fam
stop pause the video right now head on
over to patreon.com
and get yourself that second fruitella
yes sir go and get that Juicy Juice yeah
man that's satiated yeah painting burst
that burst only gonna cost you three
pound a month 10p a day bro yeah yeah if
you want a free tell every week it's
actually probably gonna cost you more
it's gonna cost you more than that if
you wanted to eat some sweets every week
it will cost you more than 50 facts so
guys head on over patreon.com
and you'll have all the back of log of
our years of episodes that we've done
over there
um as well as a new episode every
Thursday as well as access to our Hub
over on Discord where everyone's chirps
in everyone's dating everyone's getting
the the juicy gossip everyone's yeah
everyone's doing that right
everyone's doing that bridge one over
there so guys head on over there and
become a true cult
baby
um guys obviously real quick if you are
watching on YouTube please it would mean
the world to us if you like the video if
you like the video comment subscribe to
the channel most of all okay
notifications on because we just post
these days we're just posting yeah yeah
and things everyone's trying to get in
there like haha first but you're not
you're like yeah yeah yeah 19th yeah put
the Bell on yeah so you can actually be
first
um because your boys are racking in
hundreds of thousands of views now it's
getting a bit silly weekly um so guys
yeah
subscribe to the channel if you watch on
YouTube and lastly guys if you listen to
the episodes on audio podcast platforms
please leave a nice review five stars is
preferable but whatever you do say with
your chest okay guys and without any
further Ado my comrade firelord phase is
gonna
hit us I just burped hit us with some
knowledge today please what is the fun
fact today fun fact of the day today
guys is middle school girl Stills 10K
from her grandparents and passes it out
to her classmates
wow yeah Florida Jesus
Florida girl breaks into a safe gives
10K to students or going into ABC News a
14 year old girl caused a stir up in
North Florida middle school this week
when she handed up more than ten
thousand dollars that official Century
store from my grandmother safe Marion
County deputies responded to Lake Weir
Middle School in Summerfield on Thursday
after reports that said that student was
giving out hundreds of dollars to each a
hundred dollars each to each student
school officials searched the girl's
backpack and found about 2 500 that the
deputy said the team said an unknown
former student had given her the money
and wanted it disseminated
investigators said they later determined
that the goal had broken into her
grandmother's home her grandmother's
home safe sorry and stole 13 500 of the
woman's life savings just to dish out
bro it's your grandma's your family
why the what was the motive bro that's
what I'm saying what the [ __ ] why if why
the hell would anyone do that
Jesus what kind of flex is that you're
you're stealing money to give money out
to people to just make people in school
yeah yeah you think you're okay but it's
not like you're not providing a service
just I tell you what she's been watching
too many Mr Beast videos
that brother just gives money away uh
Halloween he was giving out iPhones
giving out PlayStations yeah oh he was
giving stuff out yeah yeah these are
watching Mr Beast thinking if I want to
be popular yeah
because now she's the popular girl in
school yeah she's she's 10 racks going
yeah but then she doesn't realize that
[ __ ] stay hungry bro if you're running
me 100 today run me two tomorrow run me
two tomorrow or we're gonna fight yeah
we're gonna fight because now you'll
know fam you're known as 10 racks Rachel
yes so Rachel where is my pee because
every week I need that tax it's been
Wednesday it's been Wednesday and I
haven't seen my money I haven't seen
money so what scan yeah so if you're not
going to free it up anymore I'm just
gonna start taking it I'm gonna start
taking it and it could get violent yeah
it could get physical 100 will get
physical because I want it
and I just took out a new phone contract
for no reason yeah for no reason because
you're freeing up money so keep it
running keep it running or else you're
gonna get hurt yeah otherwise I'm gonna
have to shut your kidney
hahaha
because I need to make Bank
yes facts that's that's wild that's wild
stupid I couldn't some I hear this story
sometimes when you say about our kids
doing this kids with that yeah yeah and
then if my child did that to me I just
wouldn't I think I'd have to just look
past it because I don't have the mental
capacity to understand why why or even
care why it's just like what you do what
what is this bro just just [ __ ] off and
don't do it again please please bro
please just don't touch get your hands
with my money I would the thing is I
wouldn't necessarily
so I would care why but I wouldn't
understand why I'd never understand why
I would never understand doing something
like ingenious like you're not even yeah
you're not providing a survey you're
literally not providing a service you're
just you're stealing from me and you're
just you're just doing that Robin Hood
for literally doing that Robin Hood you
might as well take a throat in a bin
yeah you might as well have done that
I would rather because I'd be able to
wrap my head around because now I know
it's you just you just don't like me we
can understand something yeah but if
you're just out here taking and just
giving away it's a clouting you're
searching for yeah yeah yeah and I need
to understand the hierarchy in your
school because I don't know why you're
doing this yeah and I'm doing this for
why exactly if if you're giving it to so
many people not just one person why are
you doing this who are you doing this
for bro show me The Tick Tock that you
that you made show me you did something
yeah it's something yeah yeah because I
just can't otherwise I won't sleep Fab
I'll never sleep again yeah yes it's
long it's long it's like in Hell bro
stupid
um that's wild anyway you want to grill
us on some football stuff right
um so yeah United playing Europa League
um in February February 16th a day
before my birthday
um so we play an away again we got drawn
against
um Barcelona Barcelona
um had Barcelona came second in their
Champions League group so they got
demoted to the Europa League and we came
second oh they came third second or
third I can't remember and we came
second our Europa League group so we
have to play a playoff game against the
team that got demoted from the Champions
League say less and it is against
Barcelona yeah
but the thing I wanted to actually talk
about is Toby doesn't know this yet but
next year I watch I actually want to
start to go to more European away games
so I want to go with Toby oh and I feel
like well the reason I want to go to is
obviously he loves football too he's a
United fan but I don't want to just do
it with United I want to go to like a
random European country let's say for
example I want to go to Italy I would
just love to see Juventus play yeah do
you know what I mean yeah and I want to
Vlog it and record it and I want to see
how just how what that lifestyle will
bring because I feel like it will be a
great experience considering the amount
of people that know I love football and
stuff it's just something I wanna try in
do a couple times to see if I can
replicate it because I feel like it's
something I'll get used to and something
like something that I'd enjoy but yeah
it was just a random little topic that I
wanted to talk about but I feel like
Toby doesn't know yet but it's gonna
happen he doesn't know it yet so Toby
whenever you miss this episode
next year we're doing up tours we're
doing up tours we're going to watch
football bear different countries
different seasons yeah bro but yeah I
really want to go to the um
the Barcelona game because I've never
been to the company I've never even been
to Barcelona and that stadium is it
looks fantastic I've seen the seat yeah
it looks it looks incredible so I would
love to see um United play Barcelona
because we play there first before we
come home I think the week after okay on
the 23rd yeah I thought you reckon
you're gonna get smacked
um I the thing is I don't think so
purely because Barcelona haven't been
the Barcelona of not even old yes the
years as of recent in the last couple
years and in the group stages yes their
Champions League group stage was tough
because they had they had Bayern Munich
I can't remember what else they had but
they came third or something they didn't
really do that well but I still feel
like we'll tuck them in as on both legs
I mean not not not necessarily maybe
we'd beat them both legs but I think
it's an overall I mean sorry okay yeah
yeah so yeah I hope so I hope so but I
feel like the experience in Barcelona
would be [ __ ] fantastic that sounds
cool to me bro [ __ ] fantastic that
sounds very cool to me so yeah fair play
okay guys what's good let's take a very
quick break to to spread the word for
our guys and girls over at manscape guys
so real quick this holiday season I'll
be giving thanks to our friends
over at manscaped everyone loves turkey
and stuffing but you'll be looking like
a dessert
like dessert come on with the help of
manscape's performance package 4.0 these
guys are the leaders in below the waist
grooming box
and they've blessed you with the
ultimate Thanksgiving dinner topic brav
tell your in-laws about your new Cutting
Edge ball trimmer and gift yourself or
the man in your life the ultimate men's
hygiene bundle guys trim your pumpkins
by going to manscape.com and using the
code sng Sierra November golf for free
shipping and 20 off guys thank you very
much let's get back to the episode
um right I've actually got a fan request
for us oh hit me I feel like I have
another funnel because you have it
when you said it
cool right this one made me laugh run
already right
yeah so man said
fellas I've got a weird question that's
just happened
and so it's kind of like what would you
do situation yeah
so Matt said I'm a man of Simple
Pleasures
and I'm saying that if I need to [ __ ]
unfortunately I will do so in public
bathrooms oh okay ma'am yeah I said so I
was in the bathroom and I'm not a quick
[ __ ] I take my time it's America not
a Sprint fam you have to you yeah you
have to take your time I was sitting
there listening to your pod and playing
on my phone when I hear the dawn the
doorknob jiggling
that was scare me public bathroom don't
scare me because it's almost jiggling
man said I lowered my voice and said in
here
in here in here yeah I said hello my
voice and said in here yeah
I heard it again nah so I said in here
again yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah in here
yeah I'm here I'm in here in here stop
fam
the man soon stopped but the problem was
once I walked out he was standing there
no he was not James we locked eyes and I
immediately left and I said how would
you feel in that moment that's a
confrontation bro because it will make
me seem as if it will make me feel as if
sorry
he knew I was in there he knew who I was
and it's like I owe him money I felt
like a pawn in this whole thing yeah you
know what I mean that's not that's not
okay that will frighten the life oh that
was scared of [ __ ] I mean literally it
was going to show me because yeah if
he's jiggling and I'm just like in here
fam I'll keep occupied occupied oh but
like the thing is what he's good save
I don't know what to say yeah I don't
know what the terminology is so I
probably end up greeting him you know
what I mean and the things are jiggling
I'm like yo yo
all gone yo that's a greeting you know
yeah if I won't be in there just so
nervous yeah yeah like I don't know
maybe I'd want to like let him know I'm
in here without telling him yeah
fam that's exactly what I'd cough I
clear my throat because your whole mood
is shifted because he said he was
listening to us before yeah so he's like
he's just
carrying on with these days just nothing
I'm not telling anyone I'm in there
because the first one I wouldn't even
cough the first one yeah I'm sitting
there and I'm staring at the door I'm
freezing turning my um my um the podcast
on mute oh what I'm clicking my airport
to stop yeah and I'm holding my breath
I'm raising my legs I'm staring at the
table I'm holding my breath yeah and I'm
thinking don't [ __ ] don't [ __ ] don't
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] don't [ __ ] no [ __ ]
because he can't hear that yeah
yeah he can't hear that when he's just
when he's
when he's trying to enter yeah
the maddest thing is he's been in there
for five minutes he knows you're in
there oh bro he knows you're right he's
the thing is as well the reason he
jiggled the door is because he's been
waiting he saw the thing said engaged
he's gonna wait and wait and waiting
hasn't heard anything and he's like is
that even anyone in there yeah yeah
I wouldn't make I probably hold my
breath if I must wait and then he leaves
it alone and then I'd carry on relax
down and then if he did it again
that's when I'll be that yo yo stop it
yo stop it and I can't say I'm in here
I could never be like in sorry I'm in it
nah that's horrible that's [ __ ]
horrible and then you finish your thing
you wait another five minutes goes so
you told him I'm in here these routers
twice you said I'm in here
he doesn't say anything I think he's
well he's not even saying sorry
all we know is this he's new yeah yeah
it's like a horror man you just hear the
footsteps step back
and then you're like
you're carrying [ __ ] things I can't yeah
I won't be able to carry because
psychologically I'm like I can't hear
anything else has he gone into another
cubicle has he left the public domain I
like this myself is gone no I won't be
able to [ __ ] with confidence yeah not
with confidence but I'd need to finish I
know I'm not a human being I know but
it's I would have to finish but I'd be
so nervous to finish I'll be terrified
but then to find out if I've been in
there another five minutes after that
and then I open the door and he's just
sad you're just waiting for me just
staring at you not even like just
handing pocket on his phone and he's
staring at you but I'm just staring at
you and then he checks his watch
it's been 15 minutes he checks his watch
slides past you and then as he goes in
there you can even like
nah man okay what did you expect golf
what did you expect and die off I'm
leaving I'm leaving nah that's bars bro
that's a confrontation that's the that's
my worst nightmare wow that's my worst
nightmare I wouldn't I promise you after
that I would never [ __ ] in public ever
ever oh Rags Rags never ever get I don't
even like [ __ ] in my yard with the
door open when no one's in the yard
do I mean I still close enough yeah oh
yeah and look I love the bathroom nah
there's no one in the air I'm closing
door unlocked yeah I close I don't lock
it I lock it
why are you looking at it brother no bro
I lock it tight habit probably yeah and
then I sit on tick tock
I sit on Tick Tock oh my God Jesus my
toes turn blue
gassed
um bro that's hilarious oh yeah I have
to that's that's my fear that's the
confrontation that's my fear the second
rattle no that will scare the life out
of me
yeah because I know for a fact my
cubicle isn't the only cubicle in this
venue yeah go somewhere go somewhere
else why are you doing it again why are
you trying to antagonize me because you
don't know who I am and you don't know
what I'm capable of you don't know what
I've got in here do you know what I mean
you don't know what I'm doing in it oh
my God that will scare me yeah that's a
level of confidence I would never want
to see on someone else can you imagine
that's what the whole time I'll be in
there thinking what kind of sick [ __ ]
what kind of human are you listens to me
tell him I'm in here and then rattles
the thing a second time just literally
just for [ __ ] just hurry up hurry up
hurry up
nah bro you know because he heard me say
I'm here Fox he did hurry up rattles
anchors hurry up
hurry up little [ __ ] now he could yeah
I promise you that that could never
happen
because now I can't come out yeah yeah
yeah yeah come on because he's gonna
look at me and kiss his teeth on me and
I can't even protect myself I protect
myself baby you open it when he's
blocking the door he's just standing
there blocking the door
you're like Excuse me yes excuse me I
said don't tell you to hurry up hurry up
no imagine if you just push you to
decide to get in fap Bang
and he walked he doesn't he doesn't go
like this he walks forward he walks
forward you have to inhale so he doesn't
touch you and then you slide out that's
horrible that is horrible bro I said I
said hurry up
imagine he imagine you've um or he's
rattled it again and you say I'm in here
I'm in here and he's like all right cool
cool cool cool cool
and you try and finish your thing and
all you hear is a run-up and then he
bites
no no no no
I said hurry up
I need it
[Music]
hurry up I need it no no no no it was it
time your world would stop what is it is
it me yes
my [ __ ] what do you need my [ __ ] my
butt [ __ ] what do you want my [ __ ]
yeah
you need my [ __ ]
I said I need it
with his elbow
you just feel the whole thing bounce
brother
because you're not listening to the
podcast on loud anymore no no no it's
like mediums you can hear the
surroundings no no no no you're not
really paying attention and you know
listen to me I said no no hurry up I
said hurry up
I need this I need it no
crying in silence
I'll be crying in complete Dead Silence
I would message you my location help me
you just see my face of once I just pop
up
I'll send you a selfie help me
send you my location help me James
please um yeah you but the thing is
don't you have to be ambiguous because
you can't tell me what's going on
because I'm not coming oh yeah
there's a guy trying to barge down the
door and he keeps saying hurry up
because I need it
oh my God that's horrible wow that's an
interesting scenario that wasn't
interesting Jesus Christ right you've
got trash news for us right yeah I do
have a trust news for you let me just
find it so uh Manny mace actually sent
this to me
um in fact for a second I was like who
I was staring outside I was like who
there it is just waiting for it to click
yeah big money mates from Patriot sent
this to me uh jealous wife stabs husband
after mistaking explicit snaps of
herself for another woman I had this one
in my oh so yeah you've seen it as well
[ __ ] hell yeah Lenora was arrested
after allegedly stabbing her husband
during a row about explicit sex photos
she found and failed to recognize her
younger self
because she had a banging figure back
yeah back then and now she's she's
obviously not the one she's not the one
now she's thinking who the [ __ ] is that
anyway
a jealous wife allegedly stabbed her
husband after finding photos of of sorry
a jealous wife allegedly stabbed her
husband after finding photos of him in
bed with a younger woman not realizing
it was actually her identifies
identified as Lenora she was arrested
after the neighbors alerted police to
screaming and shouting at their home she
shares with her partner in Mexico
according to the reports
um the accused husband referred to only
as Juan was found to miss horse was
found to have been stabbed several times
in her arms and legs oh my God she
didn't even want to kill him she just
wanted to hurt him he's like you're not
the moving again
you're never moving again Lenora has
supposedly discovered that the snaps on
Juan's mobile phone and mistook them for
proof that he had cheated on her
she is also she is also said to have
held insults at him during the violent
attack where the husband eventually able
uh with her husband eventually able to
wrestle the knife away from her Juan
didn't explain the explicit photos were
from years ago when they first met when
the Nora couldn't even recognize her
younger self he told the police he found
the snaps in an old phone and emailed
and transferred them to his new phone
that's the reason why she saw them can
you imagine bro did she not clock that
he looks younger as well bro she just
saw she probably saw his face she saw
tits and saw red that's one and that's
not me yeah that's not two that's one
and that's not two yeah and I was like
what grabbed a knife established several
times in his legs and arms he must have
rocked her face oh one million there is
no way in hell there's no winner I'm
just chilling in my room doing whatever
and my wife bursts through the door like
Mama Tried to burst through the [ __ ]
toilet door I need it I need it she
burst music I was like who the [ __ ] is
that and I'm like what are you on about
Lenora fam stab stabs that before you
can even answer I'm like what's up stop
stop stop like what wrong Rock I promise
Rock self-defense there is no way I'm
getting stabbed up ribs sure jab jab
she's never seen a combo like it she's
never seen you're not gonna stop
I'm just not gonna stop because
ah bro I'll be so rattled bro yeah I'll
be bleeding out oh all over and I'll be
so upset of life because now it's all
done bro the whole thing is done you're
marked I'm mad
yeah I don't know if I'm gonna make it
um you know you're still gonna live yeah
I've rocked your ribs you can't breathe
for a couple seconds yeah you won't eat
right again
I don't know if I'm gonna make it and we
live in Mexico I don't know what the the
service is like here I don't know what
an ambulances are saying yeah you know
what I'm saying they're gonna take yeah
sorry no um I promise you I'm gonna say
bang rib Bang Bang all in the hips as
well yeah yeah if you twist yes bang
until that knife drops I'm coming as
well I come under a guard and just yeah
you know it's long when she comes from
this grip and switches into this oh she
flips it yeah she flips it and you're
like you've done this before serious
you've done I'll take a couple of steps
imagine not opening the door and she's
shaking and crying it's not everywhere
the thing's just like I'm just reading
my newspaper in peace
Juan and you look you just dropped the
newspaper like Juan Guan Lenora get up
what did you just say
you say Gap what did he say
this is it
was that fake Spanish what did you say
this wasn't fake I was saying what is
quiero get up
that's it you know what I said no no sir
FM she gets up close and just switches
slice slice oh slice slice because your
hands are up yes
you go to protect yourself slice what
the webbing of your fingers nah nah
she begged she bad pressure I'm telling
you slice slice the weapons dog stop
stop stop and then as I'm like watching
here she's stabbing your legs no she
goes back to the stab stab I promise you
now
one that's when I come to yeah yeah yeah
like his fight will fight because
regardless yeah yeah
she goes to one more she goes to one
more step I block her here
I block it here and then God God in the
room ribs and as she bends
and until she drops that knife I'm
telling you I'm I'm bobbing and weaving
I will [ __ ] trip her up I don't give
a [ __ ] have you seen that video of
someone tripping up little man and he
spins yeah I will trip it as a [ __ ]
there's a triple spin
she'll do a book of teaspoon of Rooney
yeah
I make her head bounce outside pause oh
I will trip up and pounce on her yeah
oh my God honestly and what sweat yeah
I'm sweating I can see it Jay bro
honestly and then as soon as I've
beat her up
I'm playing victim
he's just lying man in the pool of your
own blood I'm just lie there bleeding
because the neighbors have heard
everything yeah yeah someone cool
something someone calls someone
immediately yeah bleeding I'm the victim
so is she yeah but please protect me
yeah I need to live because I'm not to
blame and he find out because of and
then I find out and she finds out she's
talking about pictures of her of her
that I [ __ ] found on my old phone and
I put on my YouTube I'm trying to
reminisce you're the love of my life I'm
doing her old hard drives and everything
for you oh my God
and because because you can't stomach
what you see in the mirror all of a
sudden it's my fault and I'm a cheat
and I said sweet sister
that's what I know it's real that's what
I know it's real I promise you there's
no fear that I would ever feel like that
she switches my grip
that scared me
the webbing on my fingers
I can't take a cut like that can't get
anywhere else I can't take a cut like
that
bro oh I I'm saying I'm saying all of
this I'll scream and run that's the fact
the matter of factors are scream and run
as soon as she touches the weapon of my
finger I I will go and just shut up yeah
all right go I'll be coming to shock
you just see your hand bleeding
I was screaming just like dashing if she
cuts this one and I see it this Palm is
I'm slapping her with the hardest Fist
and I'm dying I promise you I'm I'm
chatting [ __ ] I'm not doing anything to
her I'll I will scream and run and I
know for a fact when I turn around I'm
gonna feel alone without my back
[Laughter]
because your yard isn't straightforward
there's nooks and crannies there's nooks
and crannies bro but I'm sure get a long
one down my back and regardless if it's
shallower deep I'm screaming and
dropping to the floor I'll beg it to
stop
I'm not doing any harm to her I'll be
scared
that scenario is so funny oh my God oh
my God I'm sweating like a [ __ ]
oh Jesus Christ Jesus man I'll be too
scared
too scared oh yeah God forbid that
happens
I'm scared the life out of me the
webbing of my fingers yeah Rags this
thing oh yes that's that's right cool so
I saw a liquid scene the other day and I
had to read the comments oh yes the
threads you said
I saw a little thing uh and it literally
just said your group chat gets leaked
what are you doing
the fan no I've not seen this I
literally just took a couple of the
comments just a couple okay premise your
group chat gets leaked what are you
doing oh my God bam and one press head
25 to life
I'm doing 25 to Life less bro 25's alive
wow
one Bray is a snake one Brand This
Thread said I'm making a deal with the
feds and I'm becoming an eyewitness at
their man's trials no throw did not I'm
covering my back that's what you said
I'm covering my back
wow eyewitness testimonies at these
man's trials
I'm not going down nah he he would
eventually die before them though
because
if the group chats leads all the
evidence is there so he doesn't have to
testify he's clearly
he's clearly in a position where he
knows he's not done as wrong as these
boys so why does he need to be why does
he need to be a snake do you know what I
mean so he doesn't go down in it
yeah but like
if he's not if all these other boys are
being I have been um incriminated in the
group chat yeah yeah and he's not been
the one incriminate at all he doesn't
need to testify but he doesn't say he
has been that's the point what he's
saying he has been incriminated oh okay
okay
okay
Slytherin type thing say less okay
Potter what a Potter yeah yeah he's
doing up Slytherin oh wow okay um one
prayer said I'm not doing nothing we
only discuss God
waste man we only discuss God uh jokes
bro I want bread finding one man said
I'll be happy because now the world can
see my friends ignoring me too
fast bro don't break me bro that would
break me sometimes you man air me in
there and it it in Fury it's not only
you it's not only you that infuriates me
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and like
when it happens I can't let it light I
have to say it
I have to say it I'll put a tumbleweed
Emoji or Tumbleweed again just stop
ignoring me like I exist
I exist and we're boys entertain me I'm
a valid member in this group facts
there's five of us in here why is it
every time Jacob wants to say something
everyone's laughing everyone I say
something no one even bothers I
Aesthetics
seen it and when I swipe right it says
red red red red
so everyone open the thing say what I
said and close their phone and got on
with their day got on with the day bro
you know what annoys me the most is when
I lose um
when I am third or fourth to wish
someone happy birthday
I can't even mean it
oh
and someone was like yo happy birthday
because it's love the first one is
always love love love love and then I'm
asleep I wake up
happy birthday bro you don't even reply
bro just double tap yeah
it looks like I don't give a [ __ ] like
what have you been doing why have you
wished me happy birthday yeah we were
doing that parties yeah and now you have
the audacity to message me at 8am 8
hours later my birthday's been pretty
gone my birthday's basically been and
gone are you doing up hbd HDD
HPD get out of it get off of that [ __ ] I
just double time huh
you're doing up HP just jokes that's
funny bro that's funny I group chat I'm
trying to think if our group chat got
leaked what what would what would we
suffer I don't think it'd be that bad
I don't think it would be bad
maybe like not maybe back in uni days
because our group chat's been going on
for over a decade oh yeah so yeah
there's archives exactly there's
archives and I've never deleted our chat
I don't think I have so have I I
remember one time I was suffer I might
have actually I might have played a good
few years worth because one time my
WhatsApp data was my memory on my phone
so I was suffering yeah yeah and it said
what's I'm the number one culprit with
what's that number one culprit yeah I
was like swear I went in there then I
see I'm seeing obviously chat open for
years and years and years I was like all
right come on let's let's get rid of
some of this but [ __ ] you know man that
one made me laugh
um but anyway guys we're gonna wrap it
there for today thank you for hanging
with us
um have a great week as always head on
over to patreon.com shits and gigs for
our next episode on Thursday and um
[Music]
foreign